mais d'abord donc cette question les
Galeries Lafayette pourraient-elles
mettre la clé sous la porte 26 magasins
de cette enseigne situé en région
seraient en grande difficulté ce sont
ceux racheter par l'homme d'affaires
Michel oillon c'est lui qui possède
également camaïeu et Go Sport les 26
magasins franchisés qu'il possède dont
celui de tour viennent d'être placé sous
sauvegarde les explications de Faustine
Luneau
cela fait près de 30 ans en 1995 pour
être exact que l'enseigne des Galeries
Lafayette à sa place sur la rue
Nationale c'est donc un magasin
iconique à tour qui est en difficulté
aujourd'hui comme 25 autres en France
c'est quand même un magasin auquel on
est attaché depuis plusieurs décennies
que pour moi c'est comme une institution
les Galeries Lafayette ici rue Nationale
je crois que ça a toujours existé enfin
pour moi ça a toujours existé il n'est
pas encore prévu que les galeries de
Tours ferme pour l'instant une procédure
de sauvegarde demandée par la société
financière à la tête des magasins dont
celui de tour depuis 2021 a été validé
par le Tribunal de Commerce de Bordeaux
la grande différence entre le plan de
sauvegarde et les autres procédures la
procédure de liquidation ou de
redressement judiciaire c'est que
l'entreprise n'est pas en cessation de
paiement et qu'elle demande la
protection de la justice qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire en fait elle demande à ce
que toutes ses dettes soient suspendues
par exemple ici le patron des Galeries
Lafayette Michel Wayon ne paiera plus
son loyer ne payera plus les charges
sociales ne payera plus ses impôts
pendant une période de six mois c'est ce
qui a indiqué le tribunal il y a une
période de sauvegarde avec observation
de six mois dans ce plan de sauvegarde
pour l'instant aucun licenciement et le
groupe dispose d'une trésorerie
suffisante pour garantir les salaires
pendant plusieurs mois mais cette
solution reste provisoire à Tours les
galeries emploi environ 150 personnes et
c'est le groupe du taux qui en possède
les murs